it was an impressive Victory and an
unprecedented third term for taiwan's
Democratic Progressive Party but a note
of caution from the president elect to
his supporters they didn't get
everything their
way in the legislative elections the DPP
did not hold on to a majority this means
that we did not work hard enough and
there are areas where we must humbly
review and look
back the Nationalist AMT party Now
controls the largest Block in the
legislature by a thin margin even if
they failed again to get the top job
even the Taiwan People's Party who
finished third have a significant voting
block potential King
makers International recognition of Li's
victory was muted many leaders aware
that China will not be pleased by his
success Joe Biden's initial
reaction we do not support
Independence a curious statement from a
friend that's committed to your defense
grew up being but was that message for
the people of Taiwan or the leaders in
Beijing probably a little bit of both I
think the first audience in mind is
likely Beijing that um us is telling
Beijing that hey uh they have a pro us
toan Tha Canada is coming into Power
however that does not mean that us
intend to do anything that would
dramatically come anywhere near Crossing
beijing's red
lines maintaining the status quo appears
to be what taiwan's voters really want
and they don't have to look far to see
the dangers of a president with
unchecked powers and control Taiwanese
voters have made a very particular
choice they've elected a DPP president
he going to give them continuity and
stability but at the same time his
powers are going to be kept in check by
A legislature he doesn't control Tony
Chang Al jazer
Tai make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer